you made it welcome to the fail gate I  don't get it we have to go watch the  teams that beat us oh god no we drink a  lot and try to forget the postseason Oh  hold up there's a postseason I'll get it  who are all these excited people Jared  these are fans  I've heard about that do you have fans  yeah I did hey Bills fans look I hate  tables too Nathan no you do not have the  coordination bills mafia my eye  [Music]  tickets tickets just thousands of  tickets that we no longer need franchise  quarterback got your franchise  quarterback here anyone looking for a  franchise quarterback only thirty  million dollars yeah um I'm interested  coach come on we gotta go beat the Pats  not a catch Oh  yohoo it's a shotgun oh hell yeah come  on hurry up in there balls